[Music]
another ticket serving the homeless City
of Houston these cops are sighting
people for the heinous offense of
feeding the homeless Philip aone who
Volunteers in Houston with the charity
group food not bombs went on trial this
summer for helping the poor thanks to an
ordinance that makes it illegal to sore
food to the hungry in many areas but
Houston isn't the only place with these
rules last year an elderly Arizona woman
was arrested for feeding the homeless in
a public park and a few years before
that cops in Kansas City poured bleach
on food me for the needy because the
group ding it out didn't have a permit
several of these rules make an
interesting exception you can share food
as long as it's with people who aren't
in need that's one reason why many say
this violates the First Amendment so
what happened to pone his trial forced
the government to argue in public that
people should be punished for helping
the poor and a jury acquitted him
because they saw that for what it was